by user throw away repeat each person
generates five tons of waste a year but
if nature can recycle itself
why not humans time for a lifestyle
revolution owning the good makes sense
if that good increases in value so
owning a house makes sense owning any
disposable good doesn't make sense the
circular economy is the ultimate
recycling concept no more waste but it
could also increase GDP by 1% say the
landscape from these eyesores and save
the planet from an ecological disaster
currently 1.5 planets worth of resources
are being used to produce goods and
absorbed waste but how can one man's
waste become another's raw material
everything starts with good thinking
with good materials and product design
the products need to be upgradeable not
just reusable but upgradable reusable
repairable and recyclable innovation -
is catching on awesome entrepreneur hope
risk is basically don't at Monaco here
is only a few a leaky completely secure
is a man Luca des entreprises in a 302
here we'd be his only frequent in
Oakland and hunt Harvick asylum is not
plus the new Verity tech Thank You Barry
they decide package doctors doctors
document but at the grand unveiling at
the plenary and the Commission didn't
need one and a half he had to come back
with such a bad proposal plans do
include a common EU target to recycle
65% of municipal waste and 75% of
packaging waste by 2030
but these targets have been downgraded
from a previous package there is new
target for resource efficiency there are
no links to the European semester the
on landfilling disappeared from the new
material with the Parliament unhappy
could the new proposal be headed for the
scrap heap